I was talking to him about this once and he was like, that is the definition of feature creep, right there. You started off wanting to call sort and you've ended up with 18,000 lines of code that implements the whole of the range of CS. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 125 recorded on April 5th 2023. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce we interview Tristan Brindle about collection oriented programming, his nano range library and more. All right we will just hop straight into things um are you in london uh i am well actually a little town just just on the outskirts of london okay uh but are you and bryce are you going to c++ on c
I was talking to him about this once and he was like, that is the definition of feature creep, right there. You started off wanting to call sort and you've ended up with 18,000 lines of code that implements the whole of the range of CS. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 125 recorded on April 5th 2023. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce we interview Tristan Brindle about collection oriented programming, his nano range library and more. All right we will just hop straight into things um are you in london uh i am well actually a little town just just on the outskirts of london okay uh but are you and bryce are you going to c++ on c|||我曾经和他聊过这个，他当时就说：“这简直就是功能蔓延（feature creep）的教科书级定义。”你一开始只是想调用一下sort，结果却写了18,000行代码来实现了整个ranges TS。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 125 期，录制于 2023 年 4 月 5 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）一起采访特里斯坦·布林德尔（Tristan Brindle），聊聊面向集合的编程、他的 nano range 库等等。好的，我们直接切入正题，嗯，你在伦敦吗？呃，我……其实是在伦敦郊外的一个小镇上。好吧，呃，你和布莱斯，你们要去参加 C++ on Sea 吗？
yeah yeah i'm going to london three times in the next wait three three times in the next couple months i'll be in london for like a day before are you going to c++ on c2 tristan i am i am yeah we'll see we'll see each other there then so i was gonna say we should meet up in london you've this was dangerous information to give me because now i have another name of a person whose couch i can try to crash on every time i come through london um yeah you can try yeah i'm gonna be there for um on my way to core c++ um for cpp on c and then in two weeks for accu man why do you count why do you count your layovers that's not like in this case it's i'm actually there for a day. I fly in and I have to. No, that was cool.
yeah yeah i'm going to london three times in the next wait three three times in the next couple months i'll be in london for like a day before are you going to c++ on c2 tristan i am i am yeah we'll see we'll see each other there then so i was gonna say we should meet up in london you've this was dangerous information to give me because now i have another name of a person whose couch i can try to crash on every time i come through london um yeah you can try yeah i'm gonna be there for um on my way to core c++ um for cpp on c and then in two weeks for accu man why do you count why do you count your layovers that's not like in this case it's i'm actually there for a day. I fly in and I have to. No, that was cool.|||对，对，接下来的几个月里我要去三次伦敦——等等，三次。接下来的几个月里会有三次，我会去伦敦呆上一天左右。特里斯坦，你要去 C++ on Sea 吗？我会去，我会去的。太好了，那我们到时候在那儿见。我是说，我们应该在伦敦见个面。你把这个信息告诉我太危险了，因为现在我每次路过伦敦时，又多了一个可以去蹭沙发睡的人的名字。嗯，你可以试试。是的，我会在……在去 Core C++ 的路上，去参加 CPP on Sea，然后在两周后参加 ACCU。天哪，你为什么要把转机停留也算进去？那不——像这种情况下，我确实在那儿待了一天。我飞过去，我必须……不，这挺酷的。
So, yeah, this is the problem. I don't have any cool stories like Sean, obviously. I've never met Steve Jobs. And I was never in the army. So I just I don't know where my stories are going to come from. I feel like you probably everyone. I think that's the thing is everyone doesn't think their stories are like amazing or awesome. Yeah. But everybody has, and then they will just like incidentally tell some story and then you'll be
So, yeah, this is the problem. I don't have any cool stories like Sean, obviously. I've never met Steve Jobs. And I was never in the army. So I just I don't know where my stories are going to come from. I feel like you probably everyone. I think that's the thing is everyone doesn't think their stories are like amazing or awesome. Yeah. But everybody has, and then they will just like incidentally tell some story and then you'll be|||所以，是的，这就是问题所在。显然，我没有像肖恩（Sean）那样酷的故事。我从未见过史蒂夫·乔布斯，我也从没参过军。所以我只是……我不知道我的故事该从哪里来。我觉得你可能……每个人都是这样。我觉得这就是关键所在，每个人都觉得自己的故事其实并没有那么惊艳或厉害。是的。但每个人都有，然后他们会不经意间讲起某个故事，接着你就会——
like, what the heck you, that, and that happened. And you'll be like, Oh yeah. I mean, I guess I seemed normal at the time,
like, what the heck you, that, and that happened. And you'll be like, Oh yeah. I mean, I guess I seemed normal at the time,|||觉得：“搞什么鬼，你竟然经历过那种事？”然后你会说：“哦，对啊。我是说，当时我感觉自己挺正常的，”
but I guess from a third point party point of view, I think it's pretty rare to meet people who are actually boring. Like I, I re I really struggled to think of somebody that I know who does not have interesting facets. You've met me a couple of times. And I think you're an interesting person. I'm sure. I'm sure. You did invite me onto this for some reason. Yeah. Yeah, sure. You're under the spotlight. I know. I know. That's the problem.
but I guess from a third point party point of view, I think it's pretty rare to meet people who are actually boring. Like I, I re I really struggled to think of somebody that I know who does not have interesting facets. You've met me a couple of times. And I think you're an interesting person. I'm sure. I'm sure. You did invite me onto this for some reason. Yeah. Yeah, sure. You're under the spotlight. I know. I know. That's the problem.|||“但从第三方的角度来看，我觉得要遇到真正无聊的人其实挺罕见的。”比如我，我真的很难想出一个我认识的、身上没有有趣之处的人。你已经见过我好几次了。而且我觉得你就是一个有趣的人。我确信，我确信。你确实出于某种原因邀请我上了这个节目。对，对，当然。你现在是焦点人物了。我知道，我知道。这就是问题所在。
Yeah, we are a, we are angrowing, we're the fastest growing, and we're now officially, oh, we never brought that up. So for the longest time, depending on what podcast app statistics you look at, we were behind CPP chat, which is now discontinued, I think forever discontinued. I actually don't know the status.
Yeah, we are a, we are angrowing, we're the fastest growing, and we're now officially, oh, we never brought that up. So for the longest time, depending on what podcast app statistics you look at, we were behind CPP chat, which is now discontinued, I think forever discontinued. I actually don't know the status.|||是的，我们是一个……我们在不断成长，我们是增长最快的，而且我们现在正式——哦，我们从来没提过这个。很长一段时间里，根据你看的播客应用统计数据，我们一直落后于 CPP Chat，不过该节目现在已经停更了，我想是永久停更了。其实我不太清楚它的现状。
Phil Nash is always too busy skipping from podcast to podcast. And now that he's on CPP. Yeah, he's doing CPP cast now. He's like a pirate. He's like a podcast pirate, you know? He's on one podcast pirate ship and then he jumps to another podcast pirate ship
Phil Nash is always too busy skipping from podcast to podcast. And now that he's on CPP. Yeah, he's doing CPP cast now. He's like a pirate. He's like a podcast pirate, you know? He's on one podcast pirate ship and then he jumps to another podcast pirate ship|||菲尔·纳什（Phil Nash）总是忙着在各种播客之间跳来跳去。而且现在他在 CPP 上——对，他现在在做 CPP Cast。他就像个海盗，你知道吗？就像个播客海盗！他先是在一艘播客海盗船上，然后又跳到了另一艘播客海盗船上，
and then he saw this like slowly sinking CPP cast, you know, pirate ship. And then he was like, I'm going to take that back and bring it back to life. He and Tim were doing a really good job with CppCast. I think
and then he saw this like slowly sinking CPP cast, you know, pirate ship. And then he was like, I'm going to take that back and bring it back to life. He and Tim were doing a really good job with CppCast. I think|||然后他看到了这艘徐徐下沉的 CPP Cast（你知道的）海盗船，接着他就想：“我要把它夺回来，让它重焕生机。”他和蒂姆（Tim）在 CppCast 上做得非常出色。我觉得
I've really enjoyed their content since it's come back. Yeah, they've had some interesting guests. Okay, now I feel like we're done warming up. Whether or not, we'll see what makes it into the Go for it. Into the actual final cut. You have a topic in mind, Connor, right?
I've really enjoyed their content since it's come back. Yeah, they've had some interesting guests. Okay, now I feel like we're done warming up. Whether or not, we'll see what makes it into the Go for it. Into the actual final cut. You have a topic in mind, Connor, right?|||自从它回归以来，我真的很喜欢他们的内容。对，他们请到了一些很有意思的嘉宾。好了，现在我觉得热身结束了。不管怎样，我们到时候看看什么内容能进入最终剪辑。康纳，你心里有个主题对吧？
Yeah. Well, I'm not sure. Did you see it? Well, first of all, let's introduce Tristan Brindle as our guest today. This interview is kind of happening because let me bring up the email. I did link to both of them. So what's the date on this? It's February 9th 2023 uh tristan who i mean i assume most
Yeah. Well, I'm not sure. Did you see it? Well, first of all, let's introduce Tristan Brindle as our guest today. This interview is kind of happening because let me bring up the email. I did link to both of them. So what's the date on this? It's February 9th 2023 uh tristan who i mean i assume most|||对。嗯，我不确定。你看到了吗？好吧，首先，让我们隆重介绍今天的嘉宾特里斯坦·布林德尔（Tristan Brindle）。这次采访之所以能成行，是因为——让调出那封邮件。我确实把这两者链接起来了。那这封邮件的日期是什么时候？是 2023 年 2 月 9 日。呃，特里斯坦，我——我的意思是，我猜大多数
listeners know that you know we know a lot of the people that we're bringing on but we've all met obviously at multiple conferences and committee meetings um actually yeah when was the first time we met tristan maybe it was cpp con 2019. Probably. That sounds about right. Yeah. I've never been to C++ now. I'd love to go, but yeah. So prolific speaker, many topics. We'll link a bunch of them in the show notes. I think ranges is primarily like the majority of the talks that I've seen by you. Yeah. Yeah. That's kind of the subject that I've given a few talks on. And actually, before we get back to the tweet that brought this interview slash conversation to you today, I think the very first time I came across your name was you were on CppCast as a one of three guests correct me if i'm wrong that was talking about
listeners know that you know we know a lot of the people that we're bringing on but we've all met obviously at multiple conferences and committee meetings um actually yeah when was the first time we met tristan maybe it was cpp con 2019. Probably. That sounds about right. Yeah. I've never been to C++ now. I'd love to go, but yeah. So prolific speaker, many topics. We'll link a bunch of them in the show notes. I think ranges is primarily like the majority of the talks that I've seen by you. Yeah. Yeah. That's kind of the subject that I've given a few talks on. And actually, before we get back to the tweet that brought this interview slash conversation to you today, I think the very first time I came across your name was you were on CppCast as a one of three guests correct me if i'm wrong that was talking about|||听众都知道，我们请来的很多嘉宾其实我们都认识，因为我们显然都在各种会议和委员会会议上见过面。嗯，实际上，对啊，我们第一次见面是什么时候，特里斯坦？也许是 2019 年的 CppCon 吧。很可能是。听起来差不多。是的。我从来没去过 C++ Now。我很想去，但——是的。所以（你是一位）高产的演讲者，讲过许多主题。我们会在节目文稿中给出其中许多演讲的链接。我想，我看到的你的演讲大部分都与 ranges 有关。对，对。那确实是我做过几次演讲的主题。其实，在我们回到促成今天这次采访/对话的那条推文之前，我想我第一次看到你的名字，是因为你作为三个嘉宾之一上了 CppCast——如果我没记错的话——当时讨论的是
the cpp london university and i remember just being like in awe of the amount of work that it would take because you were saying that you basically were like marking assignments and like giving feedback and yeah conducting this kind of like online C++ course. And I was just, I don't even think at the time I had connected when I first met you that you were one of those three voices. I knew you had done the, your sort of nano, was it nano ranges? Is that what it was called? Nano range. Yeah. Yeah. And so I knew that you had implemented a bunch of ranges, like range like stuff in the range library that I think has been quite popular. And then at some point I remember that you had mentioned that you were doing this
the cpp london university and i remember just being like in awe of the amount of work that it would take because you were saying that you basically were like marking assignments and like giving feedback and yeah conducting this kind of like online C++ course. And I was just, I don't even think at the time I had connected when I first met you that you were one of those three voices. I knew you had done the, your sort of nano, was it nano ranges? Is that what it was called? Nano range. Yeah. Yeah. And so I knew that you had implemented a bunch of ranges, like range like stuff in the range library that I think has been quite popular. And then at some point I remember that you had mentioned that you were doing this|||C++ 伦敦大学（CPP London University）。我当时只觉得惊叹于这需要耗费巨大的工作量，因为你说你基本上要批改作业、给出反馈，等等，还要主持这种在线的 C++ 课程。我当时甚至觉得，当我第一次见到你时，我并没有把“你就是那三个声音之一”这件事联系起来。我当时只知道你做过那种 nano——是叫 nano ranges 吗？是叫这个名字吗？Nano range。对，对。所以我知道你实现了一堆 ranges，类似于 ranges 库里的东西，我觉得那个库挺受欢迎的。然后不知在什么时候，我记得你曾提到过你在做这个
cpp london university thing and then i was like i listened to that podcast and then i went and looked and i was like holy smokes you were one of those three voices yeah yeah so um that was uh i think that i i started with uh well uh it was started by a guy called Tom Brezza. It was an off show. There is a C++ meetup in London. It's called C++ London. It's run by Phil Nash. And it's roughly monthly.
cpp london university thing and then i was like i listened to that podcast and then i went and looked and i was like holy smokes you were one of those three voices yeah yeah so um that was uh i think that i i started with uh well uh it was started by a guy called Tom Brezza. It was an off show. There is a C++ meetup in London. It's called C++ London. It's run by Phil Nash. And it's roughly monthly.|||C++ 伦敦大学的项目，然后我就想——我听了那一期播客，接着去查了一下，当时我就惊呼：“天呐，你竟然就是那三个声音之一！”对，对。所以……嗯，那是……我想我当时是从——嗯，这个项目是由一个叫汤姆·布雷扎（Tom Brezza）的人发起的。这是一个衍生项目。伦敦有一个 C++ 聚会，叫做 C++ London。它由菲尔·纳什（Phil Nash）运营，大约每月举办一次。
And a guy called Tom, who was learning C++, started going along to these meetings, but, you know, they're for established programmers, you know, for people who use C++ all the time. And he was a learner, and he was like, it would be really cool if there was some sort of meetup for people who were learning C++. So Phil, like, emailed around everybody who was on the list for C++ London. He said, like, you know, Tom is trying to start this.
And a guy called Tom, who was learning C++, started going along to these meetings, but, you5 know, they're for established programmers, you know, for people who use C++ all the time. and he was a learner, and he was like, it would be really cool if there was some sort of meetup for people who were learning C++. So Phil, like, emailed around everybody who was on the list for C++ London. He said, like, you know, Tom is trying to start this.|||一个正在学习 C++ 的、名叫汤姆的小伙子开始去参加这些聚会，但是，你知道的，这些聚会是为成熟的程序员准备的，是为那些经常使用 C++ 的人准备的。而他当时是个初学者，他就想：“如果能有一种专门为正在学习 C++ 的人举办的聚会，那该多酷啊。”于是菲尔给 C++ London 邮件列表里的所有人发了邮件。他说：“你知道的，汤姆正试图发起这个活动。”
Would anybody fancy giving maybe a couple of classes? Maybe like five classes. Maybe we can do it in five. Maybe we can go through all of C++ in five hour-long sessions. I was like, well, I don't know about that but that that sounds that sounds like fun that sounds like something i could do so then i kind of signed up okay i'll do i'll do five sessions um and uh then very quickly another guy got involved uh called uh oliver din ollie and uh so then the three of us this just sort of this just sort of snowballed from there. And we ended up
Would anybody fancy giving maybe a couple of classes? Maybe like five classes. Maybe we can do it in five. Maybe we can go through all of C++ in five hour-long sessions. I was like, well, I don't know about that but that that sounds that sounds like fun that sounds like something i could do so then i kind of signed up okay i'll do i'll do five sessions um and uh then very quickly another guy got involved uh called uh oliver din ollie and uh so then the three of us this just sort of this just sort of snowballed from there. And we ended up|||“有没有人想去讲个几节课？大概五节课吧。也许我们可以在五节课内完成。也许我们可以通过五次一小时的课程讲完整个 C++。”当时我想：“嗯，我不知道这行不行，但这听起来……听起来挺有意思的，听起来像是我能做的事情。”于是我差不多就报名了：“好吧，我来做，我来讲五节课。”嗯，然后很快另一个人也加入了进来，他叫奥利弗·丁（Oliver Din），大家都叫他奥利（Ollie）。于是我们三个……这件事就这样像滚雪球一样发展了起来。最后我们
giving these classes, weekly classes in C++ in London for a couple of years. And then it was all going pretty well. And then unfortunately, COVID hit and there was lockdown and we weren't able to meet up anymore. And we started doing them online, like right at the start of all the COVID shutdown. But at that point, like everyone had massive Zoom fatigue, you know, because we were all spending so long all day in these Zoom meetings. And it just, you know, it sort of tailed off because we all kind of lost enthusiasm for being on Zoom in a couple of hours in the evening. So, yeah, unfortunately, COVID sort of paid to that. It would be nice to get it going again. Tom and Ollie, if you're listening to this, get in contact because I'd quite like to get it going again.
giving these classes, weekly classes in C++ in London for a couple of years. And then it was all going pretty well. And then unfortunately, COVID hit and there was lockdown and we weren't able to meet up anymore. And we started doing them online, like right at the start of all the COVID shutdown. But at that point, like everyone had massive Zoom fatigue, you know, because we were all spending so long all day in these Zoom meetings. And it just, you5 know, it sort of tailed off because we all kind of lost enthusiasm for being on Zoom in a couple of hours in the evening. So, yeah, unfortunately, COVID sort of paid to that. It would be nice to get it going again. Tom and Ollie, if you're listening to this, get in contact because I'd quite like to get it going again.|||在伦敦连续几年每周开设 C++ 课程。一切都进行得相当顺利。然而不幸的是，新冠疫情爆发了，紧接着就是封城，我们再也无法线下聚会了。在疫情封锁刚开始的时候，我们开始转到线上授课。但当时的情况是，每个人都有严重的 Zoom 疲劳，你知道的，因为我们整天都在这些 Zoom 会议上花太长时间。然后……你知道的，事情就渐渐冷清了，因为大家在傍晚花几个小时泡在 Zoom 上的热情差不多都消磨殆尽了。所以，是的，不幸的是，新冠疫情算是给这事画上了句号。如果能让它重新办起来就好了。汤姆和奥利，如果你们正在听这个节目，联系我吧，我还蛮想把它重新搞起来的。
Yeah, I remember listening to that thinking like that's such a cool thing. And also just like I've run virtual meetups before and virtual meetups are like a lot of work and just like preparing the content and the slides. And it's just a lot of work to run that. But on top of that, you were you were like doing marking and like I was just like, wow, that's like sounds like a Herac, Heraclion. That's the word Heraclion effort. And there we go. Thank you. That didn't sound right uh but yeah so you know if potentially connected some dots for some listeners that uh may know
Yeah, I remember listening to that thinking like that's such a cool thing. And also just like I've run virtual meetups before and virtual meetups are like a lot of work and just like preparing the content and the slides. And it's just a lot of work to run that. But on top of that, you were you were like doing marking and like I was just like, wow, that's like sounds like a Herac, Heraclion. That's the word Heraclion effort. And there we go. Thank you. That didn't sound right uh but yeah so you know if potentially connected some dots for some listeners that
of tristan's talks and have also listened to cppcast for a long time um and you also you did nano ranges you also were gonna this is gonna come up at some point um have a library i don't think you've really formally announced at any point called Flux, but it's, I've known about it for a while because you've, I follow you on Twitter and you've tweeted a couple of things. And then I've been like, what is this? And you were like, oh, you know, it's my unannounced library. So I feel like I'm saying it's unannounced and yet we have like several thousand people that listen to this podcast. So it's going to get a, this is the announcement. Here we are. Yes. Yes. All right. Let's, yeah, we can talk about that. So I've been working on this for a few months now,
of tristan's talks and have also listened to cppcast for a long time um and you also you did nano ranges you also were gonna this is gonna come up at some point um have a library i don't think you've really formally announced at any point called Flux, but it's, I've known about it for a while because you've, I follow you on Twitter and you've tweeted a couple of things. And then I've been like, what is this? And you were like, oh, you know, it's my unannounced library. So I feel like I'm saying it's unannounced and yet we have like several thousand people that listen to this podcast. So it's going to get a, this is the announcement. Here we are. Yes. Yes. All right. Let's, yeah, we can talk about that. So I've been working on this for a few months now,|||听过特里斯坦的演讲，并且也长时间收听 CppCast。嗯，而且你还做过 nano ranges，你还……这件事待会儿肯定也会提到……有一个库——我觉得你好像从来没有在任何场合正式宣布过它——叫做 Flux。但我其实已经知道它一段时间了，因为我关注了你的推特，你发过好几条相关的推文。当时我就在想：“这到底是什么？”而你的反应是：“哦，你知道的，这是我尚未公布的库。”所以，我觉得我一边说着它是“未公开的”，一边我们这儿有数千人在听这个播客。所以这就要——这就是官方宣布了。我们就挑明了吧。是的，是的。好吧。让我们……对，我们可以聊聊这个。所以，我开发这个库已经有几个月了。
working on a library called Flux. It's actually a follow-up, sort of a follow-up to another earlier library called Flow. But so Flux is a library for sequence- orientated programming i guess would be a good way to put it yeah yeah i don't mean in the in like the apl sense like don't get too excited connor because like i know nothing about apl or bqn or any of those uh array languages what i mean
working on a library called Flux. It's actually a follow-up, sort of a follow-up to another earlier library called Flow. But so Flux is a library for sequence- orientated programming i guess would be a good way to put it yeah yeah i don't mean in the in like the apl sense like don't get too excited connor because like i know nothing about apl or bqn or any of those uh array languages what i mean|||我一直在开发一个名为 Flux 的库。它实际上是另一个更早的库（叫做 Flow）的后续版本。不过，Flux 是一个用于“序列导向编程（sequence-oriented programming）”的库，我想这样称呼会比较贴切。对，对——我指的不是 APL 那种意义上的，康纳，你先别太激动，因为我对 APL、BQN 或者任何那些数组语言一无所知。我指的是
is sequence orientated programming in the same way that you would get with C++ ranges or Python data tools or Rust iterators or, you know, D ranges or what have you. It's a library for doing that. It shares pretty much the same goals as C++ ranges. But it takes the things that I have learned from working on C++ ranges, from implementing C++ ranges, and it does some things slightly differently. And I think these are, you know, it's an experiment. I don't know that it's, you know, it's going to work. But I'm quite excited about it. And I think it's, I think it's, I think it's I think it's pretty good really all right I've got one comment and one question so the the name of the paradigm the reason why I went is because I think
is sequence orientated programming in the same way that you would get with C++ ranges or Python data tools or Rust iterators or, you know, D ranges or what have you. It's a library for doing that. It shares pretty much the same goals as C++ ranges. But it takes the things that I have learned from working on C++ ranges, from implementing C++ ranges, and it does some things slightly differently. And I think these are, you5 know, it's an experiment. I don't know that it's, you5 know, it's going to work. But I'm quite excited about it. And I think it's, I think it's, I think it's I think it's pretty good really all right I've got one comment and one question so the the name of the paradigm the reason why I went is because I think|||序列导向编程，就像你在 C++ ranges、Python 数据工具、Rust 迭代器，或者 D 语言的 ranges 等等里面所看到的那样。它就是一个用来做这个的库。它和 C++ ranges 的目标几乎完全相同。但它汲取了我从参与 C++ ranges 工作以及实现 C++ ranges 的过程中学到的经验，并在某些地方做了一些略有不同的处理。我觉得这些……你知道的，这算是一个实验。我不知道它究竟能不能成功，但我对此感到非常兴奋。而且我觉得它……我觉得它、我觉得它……真的挺不错的。好吧，我有一个评论和一个问题。所以，这个范式的名字……我之所以选这个，是因为我觉得
I maybe mentioned it once or twice there's a paradigm called collection oriented programming which is literally what you just said like it is ranges in c++ iterators and rust and it's it's got some overlap with functional programming like i feel like spiritually functional programming and collection oriented programming are like cousins but it's the things that i actually like previously associated with functional programming like having functions that operate on sequences or you know even in small talk like small talk is not a functional language but it is a collection oriented programming language because it has all these different containers that just have operations aka what they call messages that you basically just like you build up this kind of like data flow where
I maybe mentioned it once or twice there's a paradigm called collection oriented programming which is literally what you just said like it is ranges in c++ iterators and rust and it's it's got some overlap with functional programming like i feel like spiritually functional programming and collection oriented programming are like cousins but it's the things that i actually like previously associated with functional programming like having functions that operate on sequences or you know even in small talk like small talk is not a functional language but it is a collection oriented programming language because it has all these different containers that just have operations aka what they call messages that you basically just like you build up this kind of like data flow where|||我可能在一两次提到过它。有一种范式叫做“面向集合的编程（collection-oriented programming）”，这简直就是你刚刚所描述的那样——比如 C++ 中的 ranges、Rust 中的迭代器。它与函数式编程有一些重叠之处。我觉得从精神上讲，函数式编程和面向集合的编程就像是表亲。但我真正喜欢的是那些以前与函数式编程关联在一起的东西，比如拥有能够操作序列的函数，或者甚至在 Smalltalk 中——Smalltalk 不是一门函数式语言，但它是一门面向集合的编程语言，因为它拥有所有这些不同的容器，这些容器拥有各种操作（也就是他们所说的消息），你基本上就像是在构建这样一种数据流：
you're just chaining a bunch of things together and you're never writing a for loop you're never worrying about like indexing and stuff like that you just sort of like build up this sequence of operations which is exactly what c++ 20 and 23, 26 ranges and all these types of like Java streams fits in this model. Anyways, there's going to be a talk at some point that I'll call collection-oriented programming, but it's like my favorite way to program, whether that's in Haskell or in C++ rangeland or in Smalltalk or even in like, I think there's a language called Settle, C-E-T-L, that I haven't looked at. But apparently, it's like specifically kind of like the APL, small talk kind of thing.
you're just chaining a bunch of things together and you're never writing a for loop you're never worrying about like indexing and stuff like that you just sort of like build up this sequence of operations which is exactly what c++ 20 and 23, 26 ranges and all these types of like Java streams fits in this model. Anyways, there's going to be a talk at some point that I'll call collection-oriented programming, but it's like my favorite way to program, whether that's in Haskell or in C++ rangeland or in Smalltalk or even in like, I think there's a language called Settle, C-E-T-L, that I haven't looked at. But apparently, it's like specifically kind of like the APL, small talk kind of thing.|||你只是把一堆东西串联在一起，再也无需编写 for 循环，再也不用担心索引之类的事情，你只需构建这样一系列的操作序列——这正是 C++20、C++23、C++26 的 ranges 以及所有诸如 Java Streams 之类的模型所契合的。总之，我以后某次演讲可能会把它叫做“面向集合的编程”，但这可以说是我最喜欢的编程方式，无论是用 Haskell、在 C++ 的 ranges 世界里、在 Smalltalk 中，还是甚至在——我记得有一门叫做 Settle（拼作 C-E-T-L）的语言，我还没深入了解过它，但显然它非常类似于 APL 和 Smalltalk 那种风格的东西。
But it purely works on like sets and maps. I could be wrong about that. But anyways, collection-oriented programming. Fantastic. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. So I agree with you. So I previously used the term like functional style programming.
But it purely works on like sets and maps. I could be wrong about that. But anyways, collection-oriented programming. Fantastic. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. So I agree with you. So I previously used the term like functional style programming.|||不过它纯粹是基于集合（sets）和映射（maps）来工作的。我可能记错了。但不管怎样，面向集合的编程。太棒了。对，对，对。所以我同意你的看法。我以前曾用过诸如“函数式风格编程”这样的术语。
Like functional programming means a lot of things to different people you know referential transparency and yeah all that sort of stuff uh whereas i'm more focused on like you say the bits where you you have a sequence and you manipulate it in some way you build up a pipeline of operations and um yeah so we're not not kind of full-on haskell style functional programming but uh yeah we've got one of my goals over the next one or two years is to popularize this term collection oriented programming because it is like the perfect description of what you just like described and like it it like goes across like apl small talk functional languages like apl is kind of functional but like APL, small talk, functional languages, like APL is kind of functional, but like the thing that I love about it is this composing operations or like a pipeline of operations.
Like functional programming means a lot of things to different people you know referential transparency and yeah all that sort of stuff uh whereas i'm more focused on like you say the bits where you you have a sequence and you manipulate it in some way you build up a pipeline of operations and um yeah so we're not not kind of full-on haskell style functional programming but uh yeah we've got one of my goals over the next one or two years is to popularize this term collection oriented programming because it is like the perfect description of what you just like described and like it it like goes across like apl small talk functional languages like apl is kind of functional but like APL, small talk, functional languages, like APL is kind of functional, but like the thing that I love about it is this composing operations or like a pipeline of operations.|||函数式编程对不同的人来说意味着很多不同的东西，你知道的，比如引用透明性之类的一大堆东西。而我更专注于像你所说的那些部分：你拥有一个序列，并以某种方式对其进行操作，构建一个操作管线（pipeline of operations）。嗯，所以我们并不是那种完全的 Haskell 风格的函数式编程，但是……在未来的一两年里，我的目标之一就是推广“面向集合的编程”这个术语，因为这简直是对你刚才所描述内容的完美诠释。它跨越了 APL、Smalltalk、函数式语言——比如 APL 有点像是函数式的，但……APL、Smalltalk、函数式语言，APL 虽然有点函数式色彩，但我喜欢它的地方在于这种组合操作，或者说操作管线。
And then you just feed it your data and poof, you get your answer. Like, and that is my preferred way to program in general. Like in C++, that means like doing as much range like stuff as possible. But in other languages, it just means like using the language as it's designed. Yeah, yeah yeah definitely okay so i my my term was sequence orientated programming if collection orientated programming is the uh is the the proper term then i'll i'll start using that instead because i like the proper term nobody knows but, to me, collection suggests an unordered set of things, and sequence is a thing that has... How does collection mean unordered?
And then you just feed it your data and poof, you get your answer. Like, and that is my preferred way to program in general. Like in C++, that means like doing as much range like stuff as possible. But in other languages, it just means like using the language as it's designed. Yeah, yeah yeah definitely okay so i my my term was sequence orientated programming if collection orientated programming is the
We literally... That's just what my... That's what I think in this field, when I think collection versus sequence, that's just what comes to mind to me. You're forgetting, I don't know how long ago this was, probably a year or two ago, you made me, or you made me, you nerd sniped me into doing an opposition analysis
We literally... That's just what my... That's what I think in this field, when I think collection versus sequence, that's just what comes to mind to me. You're forgetting, I don't know how long ago this was, probably a year or two ago, you made me, or you made me, you nerd sniped me into doing an opposition analysis|||我们简直……这只是我的……这就是我在这个领域里的想法，当我对比集合与序列时，脑子里自然而然就会浮现出这些。你忘了一件事——我不知道这是多久以前的事了，大概一两年前吧，你曾让我——或者说你“书呆子式地狙击（nerd sniped）”我去做了竞争分析（opposition analysis）——
of what language is called data structures because we were trying to figure out a name for the thrust equivalent of like a data structure library at NVIDIA. And we ended up coming across the terms basically containers, collections, data structures, and maybe there was one other less popular one. And we ended up going with collections. And that's why KUCO, KU Collections, is called collections because it's what many languages call their quote unquote data structures.
of what language is called data structures because we were trying to figure out a name for the thrust equivalent of like a data structure library at NVIDIA. And we ended up coming across the terms basically containers, collections, data structures, and maybe there was one other less popular one. And we ended up going with collections. And that's why KUCO, KU Collections, is called collections because it's what many languages call their quote unquote data structures.|||关于各种语言是如何称呼数据结构的，因为我们当时试图为英伟达（NVIDIA）类似于 Thrust 的数据结构库起个名字。我们最后遇到的基本术语有容器（containers）、集合（collections）、数据结构（data structures），可能还有另一个不太流行的词。我们最终选定了 collections。这就是为什么 KUCO（KU Collections）被称为 collections，因为这是许多语言对它们所谓的“数据结构”的称呼。
So I'm surprised that now your semantic attachment to collections is not just like data structures in general, but... I mean, I think that that's one of the semantic attachments that I have to it. But if I'm comparing the term with sequence, the important property that I get out of sequence is that it's a thing that I'm getting in where order is significant. That's true. So I'll add a data point on this, which is not something I know a huge amount about, but I know that in Swift, there are in the Swift standard library, there are both sequences and collections. They have sort of two iteration APIs and sequences are single sequences and collections they have sort of two iteration apis and sequences
So I'm surprised that now your semantic attachment to collections is not just like data structures in general, but... I mean, that's that's one of the semantic attachments that I have to it. But if I'm comparing the term with sequence, the important property that I get out of sequence is that it's a thing that I'm getting in where order is significant. That's true. So I'll add a data point on this, which is not something I know a huge amount about, but I know that in Swift, there are in the Swift standard library, there are both sequences and collections. They have sort of two iteration APIs and sequences are single sequences and collections they have sort of two iteration apis and sequences|||所以我很惊讶，现在你对 collections 的语义绑定居然不仅仅是泛指数据结构，而是……我的意思是，这是我对它的语义绑定之一。但如果我把这个词与 sequence 进行对比，从 sequence 中获得的一个重要特性是：它是一个我所获取的事物，且其中的顺序是至关重要的。这倒也是。那我补充一个数据点吧，虽然我对这方面了解不是特别多，但我知道在 Swift 中，在 Swift 标准库里，同时存在着 sequences（序列）和 collections（集合）。它们有两套迭代 API，其中 sequences 是单遍（single pass）的，而 collections——它们有两套迭代 API，其中 sequences
are single pass and collections are multi-pass so this was um as far as i know uh dave abrahams came up with this i believe um so he knows he knows an awful lot about these sort of things so uh yes so what sequences and collections you have like an example of what it means to be a multi-pass on a collection like uh i think the sequence single pass thing it makes pretty it's pretty straightforward you're mapping over an operation you do it whatever left to right or in some sequential order what what does it mean to i think this is about capability about whether you can consume it multiple times yeah yeah so the equivalent of a forward range in C++ land. I see, I see.
are single pass and collections are multi-pass so this was um as far as i know uh dave abrahams came up with this i believe um so he knows he knows an awful lot about these sort of things so
That makes sense. Interesting. Well, yeah, that is another data point then. I'm not sure if Swift was a language we looked at of what they called their data structures. All right, so that was the comment. The question is, let's talk about the, the differences in everything you've learned. Uh, well, so we'll link for, uh, you know, the curious listeners, I'm pretty sure NanoRange still lives online. Um, even though it was kind of designed as like for people that are in previous versions that don't have access to C++20, you can use this in the interim. So I think if I recall it it it's usable in like c++ 14 uh 17 17 um nano range yeah so just to rewind a bit so back in the ranges ts days so before this was uh standardized there was um i don't think we do them anymore do we bryce but the uh like uh ts's were was this
That makes sense. Interesting. Well, yeah, that is another data point then. I'm not sure if Swift was a language we looked at of what they called their data structures. All right, so that was the comment. The question is, let's talk about the, the differences in everything you've learned. Uh, well, so we'll link for, uh, you know, the curious listeners, I'm pretty sure NanoRange still lives online. Um, even though it was kind of designed as like for people that are in previous versions that don't have access to C++20, you can use this in the interim. So I think if I recall it it it's usable in like c++ 14
idea that we would sort of try out some new libraries with the intention that they would eventually... We've stopped doing what I like to call grab bag TSs, which are TSs that are just a collection of things without really a specific purpose. And the reason for that is that there is a high overhead to publish in something in a TS versus an IS. And if we publish it in a TS and then want to put it into the IS, we basically have to pay the standardization costs twice. Because oftentimes we have to go through and do a re-review of it because things have changed or evolved since then. And so we'll still pursue TSs, but I think the general vibe on the committee, at least in library evolution, is that we only want to see focused TSs. TSs where we have a very clear goal for why we want to pay the additional cost of putting this out into a technical specification, what questions we're hoping that it's going to answer.
idea that we would sort of try out some new libraries with the intention that they would eventually... We've stopped doing what I like to call grab bag TSs, which are TSs that are just a collection of things without really a specific purpose. And the reason for that is that there is a high overhead to publish in something in a TS versus an IS. And if we publish it in a TS and then want to put it into the IS, we basically have to pay the standardization costs twice. Because oftentimes we have to go through and do a re-review of it because things have changed or evolved since then. And so we'll still pursue TSs, but I think the general vibe on the committee, at least in library evolution, is that we only want to see focused TSs. TSs where we have a very clear goal for why we want to pay the additional cost of putting this out into a technical specification, what questions we're hoping that it's going to answer.|||那种尝试一些新库的想法，其初衷是希望它们最终能……我们已经停止做我喜欢称之为“大杂烩式 TS”的事情了。所谓大杂烩式 TS，就是仅仅把一堆东西拼凑在一起，却没有一个真正明确目的的技术规范。之所以这样做，是因为在 TS 中发布内容的开销相对于直接在 IS（国际标准）中发布要高得多。如果我们先在 TS 中发布它，然后再想把它放进 IS 中，我们基本上得支付两次标准化成本。因为通常情况下，我们必须对它进行重新审查，因为自那以后情况已经发生了变化或演进。因此，我们仍会推进 TS，但我认为委员会的普遍氛围——至少在库演进（library evolution）方面——是我们只想看到专注的（focused）TS。也就是那些拥有非常明确目标的 TS：我们为什么要为将此发布为技术规范而支付额外的成本？我们希望它能回答什么问题？
I mean, another reason that we've become more TS pessimistic is that we have found that we don't really get the usage experience in the deployment experience and the implementation experience that we had hoped with TSs, especially because we are now shipping on a three-year cycle pretty reliably. TSs were something we came up with when we were in this long, after this long decade that led to C++11, and we thought that it might be a while before we put out another standard revision. But now these days we reliably put them out every three years. And because of that, what often happens is we go through all the trouble
I mean, another reason that we've become more TS pessimistic is that we have found that we don't really get the usage experience in the deployment experience and the implementation experience that we had hoped with TSs, especially because we are now shipping on a three-year cycle pretty reliably. TSs were something we came up with when we were in this long, after this long decade that led to C++11, and we thought that it might be a while before we put out another standard revision. But now these days we reliably put them out every three years. And because of that, what often happens is we go through all the trouble|||我的意思是，我们变得对 TS 更加悲观的另一个原因在于，我们发现通过 TS 并没有真正获得我们所期望的使用体验、部署体验和实现体验，尤其是因为我们现在基本上以相当稳定的三年为一个周期进行发布。TS 是我们在经历 C++11 之前漫长的十年之后想出的办法，当时我们觉得推出下一次标准修订可能需要很长时间。但现在，我们雷打不动地每三年发布一次标准。正因为如此，经常发生的情况是：我们历经千辛万苦
to publish a TS, and then almost immediately before it even really has any time in the wild, somebody advocates for us putting it into the IS. And so we don't end up getting any experience from it and we just pay a lot of extra effort. Makes sense. Yeah, so, well, Ranges was, I think Ranges was, it was a pretty focused TS. So Eric Niebuhr came up with range V3.
to publish a TS, and then almost immediately before it even really has any time in the wild, somebody advocates for us putting it into the IS. And so we don't end up getting any experience from it and we just pay a lot of extra effort. Makes sense. Yeah, so, well, Ranges was, I think Ranges was, it was a pretty focused TS. So Eric Niebuhr came up with range V3.|||好不容易发布了一个 TS，然后几乎立刻——甚至在它真正在野外（生产环境）经历考验之前——就有人提倡把它放进 IS 里。结果我们没有从中获得任何实际经验，反而付出了大量额外的精力。这倒也说得通。是的，所以……嗯，Ranges 是——我认为 Ranges 是一个相当专注的 TS。所以埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）提出了 range-v3。
And then this went through the TS process to be standardized, eventually found its way into C++20. And back at the time when the ranges TS was published, I went and I wrote like a from scratch implementation of the ts for i started out with c++ 14 and then i moved to 17 later on because it had some uh really useful features like if constexpr and stuff um but yeah so i wrote basically my own implementation it was called nano range the idea was that you could, as you say, that you could get started with NanoRange and then whenever C++20 came along,
And then this went through the TS process to be standardized, eventually found its way into C++20. And back at the time when the ranges TS was published, I went and I wrote like a from scratch implementation of the ts for i started out with c++ 14 and then i moved to 17 later on because it had some
you could switch to that without having to use... You could use RangeV3, but RangeVC is kind of huge. And so if you wanted something that was smaller, like nano-sized, you could use NanoRange instead. So that, to be honest, it never quite got the usage that I was hoping for. I had a few people interested in it. And I believe I've seen somewhere that it's used in the Intel thread building blocks or parts of the bits of the nano-range code are used in there, which I thought, which I was, I was quite pleased about. Um, but, uh, perhaps that's not the case anymore. Uh, but, uh, yeah, so there was, there was nano range, uh, and I, I learned so much about, uh, ranges and, um, how
你可以切换到这个而不需要使用……你可以使用 RangeV3，但 RangeV3 有点庞大。所以如果你想要一个更小的、像纳米级别的东西，你可以改用 NanoRange。所以说，老实说，它从未完全获得我所希望的使用率。我有一些人对它感兴趣。而且我相信我曾在某处看到它被用于 Intel 线程构建模块中，或者说 nano-range 代码的一部分被用在里面，我觉得——我对此感到相当高兴。嗯，但是，也许现在情况已经不是这样了。嗯，但是，是的，所以有，曾经有 nano range，嗯，而且我，我学到了很多关于，嗯，ranges 以及，嗯，如何
all these things were implemented, how all these parts fit together, uh, from doing that. Before we move on, uh, how,, when I think about implementing a TS, I don't know if it's my imposter syndrome, but to me that seems like a very impenetrable wall. And I've also seen a lot of the internal range V3 code. I've also watched your talks. I've watched Christabella's talks. Also too, we should mention,
所有这些东西是如何实现的，所有这些部分是如何组合在一起的，嗯，都是通过做这件事学到的。在我们继续之前，嗯，怎么，当我考虑实现一个 TS 时，我不知道这是不是我的冒名顶替综合征，但对我来说，这似乎是一堵非常不可逾越的墙。而且我也看过很多内部的 range V3 代码。我还看过你的演讲。我也看过 Christabella 的演讲。还有，我们也应该提到，
Eric refers to Eric Niebler if you're, this is your first episode. I mean, Krista Bella's talks. Also too, we should mention, Eric refers to Eric Niebler. If, if you're, this is your, this is your first episode. I mean, we've had Eric on, so hopefully our listeners know when we say Eric, who Eric is, but like, so I've seen Eric's talks. I've seen your talks. I've seen Krista Bella's talks. Krista Bella has like a two-part CPPCon talk where he walks you through how to implement like a stride, a stride range adapter. And just like, you know, if I ever had the thought, I've had the thought of like, oh, it would be cool to implement my own like mini ranges, like similar to what you did, like only what the standard says,
Eric 指的是 Eric Niebler，如果你是，这是你的第一集。我是说，Krista Bella 的演讲。还有，我们也应该提到，Eric 指的是 Eric Niebler。如果，如果这是你的，这是你的第一集。我是说，我们请过 Eric 上节目，所以希望我们的听众当我们说 Eric 时，知道 Eric 是谁，但像，所以我看过 Eric 的演讲。我看过你的演讲。我看过 Krista Bella 的演讲。Krista Bella 有一个分为两部分的 CPPCon 演讲，他在其中带你了解如何实现类似 stride 的东西，一个 stride range 适配器。并且就像，你知道，如果我曾经有过这个想法，我曾有过这样的想法，即，哦，实现我自己的微型 ranges 会很酷，类似于你所做的那样，只包含标准所说的内容，
not a bunch of action, extra stuff that's in range V3. And then immediately my brain is just like, yeah, probably not. Like that would be so much work. And like you would immediately hit some like language lawyer wall of like having to digest like the wordies of the standard. Anyway, so my question after that long, unnecessary monologue is like, what gave you the confidence or like, and how difficult did it end up being having to implement that, you know, taking it from a TS to basically having your own library okay so to start off with i did not uh by any means intend to start out and just like start off with an empty file and go i'm going to implement the range sts um what happened was that um i was using range v3 and i was like this is really cool but like i've got to be honest like the compile times at that time were a real drag um and i was like, what I really want is to be able to call STL algorithms,
而不是 range V3 中一堆额外的动作和东西。然后我的大脑立刻就会想，嗯，大概不会吧。那会有那么多的工作量。而且你很快就会遇到一些语言极客的墙壁，比如不得不消化标准中晦涩的词句。总之，我那个冗长而不必要的独白之后的问题是，是什么给了你信心，或者说，把它从一个 TS 转化到基本上拥有你自己的库，最终到底有多难？好吧，首先，我绝不是，嗯，打算从一个空文件开始，然后说“我要实现 ranges TS”。发生的事情是，嗯，我当时正在使用 range V3，我想，这真的很酷，但说实话，当时的编译时间真的是一个沉重的负担，我想，我真正想要的是能够调用 STL 算法，
but just pass the range. So I don't have to call dot begin and dot end, you know, just sort brackets back. And I was like, okay, what I'm going to do is I'm just going to write a single header. And all it's going to do is it's just going to have some overloads of, you know, all the, well, all the useful algorithms.
但只需传入 range。这样我就不必调用 dot begin 和 dot end 了，你知道，只要加上括号就行。我想，好吧，我要做的是写一个单一的头文件。它要做的全部事情就是包含一些重载，你知道的，所有的，嗯，所有有用的算法。
And you're just going to be able to pass in a vector as well or pass in a range directly as well as these.begins,.begin,.end. And I'll just forward those calls to the existing STL, right? And then the thing is, if you start doing that, it turns out that quite quickly, you'll find out that there will be ambiguous overloads. So if you think about the example of sort, you can pass a custom comparator, right? So if you have a call to sort that has two arguments, you've got to have some way of deciding, are these two things you've given it, are they a begin and an end iterator, or are they a range and a comparator? Right? Right. So in order to do that, you need to start using, well, nowadays you could use concepts, but we didn't have concepts yet then. So I was starting to do some metaprogramming, and it's like, how do I work out whether this object is an iterator? How do I work out whether this object is an iterator?
然后你就可以直接传入一个 vector，或者直接传入一个 range，就像传入 dot begin、dot end 一样。我会把这些调用转发给现有的 STL，对吧？然后问题是，如果你开始这样做，你会发现很快就会出现模棱两可的重载。所以如果你想想 sort 的例子，你可以传入一个自定义的比较器，对吧？所以如果你有一个带有两个参数的 sort 调用，你必须有一些方法来决定，你给它的这两个东西，它们是 begin 和 end 迭代器，还是一个 range 和一个比较器？对吧？对吧？所以为了做到这一点，你需要开始使用——嗯，现在你可以使用概念（concepts），但当时我们还没有概念。所以我开始做一些元编程，就像，我如何弄清楚这个对象是否是一个迭代器？我如何弄清楚这个对象是否是一个迭代器？
How do I work out whether this object looks like a range? I was like, you know what? Some very smart people have already worked this out, and it's all written down for me in this ranges TS document. So I started off using EnableIf and all that horrible stuff we had to do at the time, all this template programming to work out, okay, this looks like a valid range. This looks like a valid iterator. And, you know, it's really pretty useful as well because it allows you to reject calls when iterators don't meet requirements and all that. So I really didn't start out intending to do the whole TS. I was like, it was just going to start out being really simple,
我如何弄清楚这个对象是否看起来像一个 range？我就想，你知道吗？一些非常聪明的人已经把这个弄明白了，这一切都写在这个 ranges TS 文档中了。所以我开始使用 EnableIf 和所有我们在当时不得不做的那些可怕的事情，所有这些模板编程来弄清楚，好吧，这看起来像一个有效的 range。这看起来像一个有效的迭代器。而且，你知道，它其实也非常有用，因为它允许你在迭代器不满足要求时拒绝调用等等。所以我真的不是一开始就打算做整个 TS 的。我想，它本来只是想变得非常简单，
just what I needed. And then I was like, okay, well, now I need to be able to differentiate between iterators and ranges and all that sort of stuff. So I'm going to take what it says in the ranges TS and do that. And I was like, you know what, this is really fun. I actually quite enjoy this. So I was like, you know what, this is really fun. I was, you know, I actually quite enjoy this. So I just ended up doing the whole thing. And the other thing that I really couldn't have done it without the help of Casey Carter, who is one of the two sort of godfathers, like the fathers, the fathers of ranges along with Eric Niebuhr. And Casey was, I was on Slack at the time,
只做我需要的部分。然后我想，好吧，现在我需要能够区分迭代器和 ranges 以及所有类似的东西。所以我要采用 ranges TS 中所说的那样去做。然后我想，你知道吗，这真的很有趣。我其实挺喜欢这个的。所以我当时就想，你知道吗，这真的很有趣。我，你知道，我其实挺享受这个的。所以我最终把整个东西都实现了。另外，如果没有 Casey Carter 的帮助，我真的不可能完成它，Casey 是 ranges 的两个教父级人物之一，与 Eric Niebler 齐名。当时我在 Slack 上，
the CPP Lang Slack, pretty much every day, just asking Casey the dumbest questions. And he was very, very patient with me, explaining stuff. We found a few bugs in the spec. And yeah, so Casey, for listening, thank you very much for your help at that time. I couldn't have done it. Yeah, he has his own version.
CPP Lang Slack，几乎每天都在向 Casey 问最愚蠢的问题。他对我非常非常有耐心，向我解释各种东西。我们在规范中发现了一些漏洞。所以，Casey，如果你在听，非常感谢你当时对我的帮助。我不可能独自完成它。是的，他有他自己的版本。
There's RangeV3, there's NanoRange, and then there's also his, which is like CMCSTL or something like that. CMCLSTL2, yeah. Which I think that was sort of the, so that used the GCC concepts TS implementation at the time. Yeah. I think that's online somewhere. So I'll link to that as well.
有 RangeV3、NanoRange，然后还有他自己的版本，类似于 CMCSTL 或者是别的什么。CMCLSTL2，是的。我想那大概是，所以当时使用了 GCC concepts TS 的实现。是的。我想那个在网上某个地方。所以我也会把链接放在那儿。
And what I was going to say is that this is, it's very inspiring to hear because as soon as you said, oh, I only just wanted to provide an overload for like existing algorithms. It's like that is- All I want to do is call sort bracket event. That sounds like my brain when I think of like,
我想说的是，这非常鼓舞人心，因为正如你所说，哦，我只是想为现有的算法提供一个重载。这就像是——我只想调用 sort 括号事件。这听起来就像我的大脑在思考，
oh, if I wanted to do that my brain goes oh yeah you can definitely provide just like an overload that dispatches to the existing thing and then from there you basically just was like oh well i just i need to know this one little thing you went to the the ts and then things snowballed from there and i could you i definitely know that like i've written things in the past where like the end thing that i ended up writing seems like a behemoth of like you know how would have i done this to begin with but like the end thing that I ended up writing seems like a behemoth of like, you know, how would I have done this to begin with? But like the initial thing that I wanted to do was just like build some small little stack machine for a small toy like calculator that ended
哦，如果我想那样做，我的大脑就会想，哦，是的，你绝对可以提供一个重载，分发到现有的东西上，然后从那里你基本上就是，哦，好吧，我只需要知道这一个小东西，你就去了 TS，然后事情就像滚雪球一样越滚越大。我确信，我绝对知道我过去写过一些东西，最终写出来的东西看起来像是一个庞然大物，你知道的，我一开始是怎么做到的？但像我最终写出来的东西看起来像是一个庞然大物，你知道的，我一开始是怎么做到的？但我最初想做的事只是为一个小型的玩具计算器构建某种小型栈机器，结果却
up being, you know, something way, way bigger. So I guess that, I guess the word of advice for the listener here is that if you're ever intimidated by some ultimate thing you want to achieve, just choose like a very small, easy part that your brain knows that you can do and go from there because that seems like it's exactly what you did and you ended up with a whole implementation of the of the ts yeah i'd say uh gashwell oaksman i think it's the same i was talking to about this once and he was like that is the definition of feature creep right there. You started off wanting to call sort and you've ended up with 18,000 lines of code that implements the whole of the ranges CS.
变成了，你知道的，大得多得多东西。所以我想，给听众的建议是，如果你对想要达到的终极目标感到恐慌或畏惧，只需选择一个你的大脑知道你能做到的非常小、非常简单的部分，然后从那里开始，因为这似乎正是你所做的，而你最终得到了整个 TS 的实现。是的，我会说，Gashwell Oaksman，我想我曾经跟他谈过这个，他说，这简直就是功能蔓延（feature creep）的定义。你一开始只想调用 sort，结果却得到了 18000 行代码，实现了整个 ranges TS。
Yeah. Yeah. Not what I started out, you know, intending to do, but somehow. Yeah. Somehow ended up with that.
是的。是的。这不是我一开始打算做的，但不知怎么的。是的。不知怎么的就成了这样。
So, yeah, that, that was, but that was a few years ago now uh now we have uh ranges in um in the standard in the standard library as well it's uh you know and i and i i love ranges i love this collection orientated stuff um i you know like you it's um i really enjoy that style of programming. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以，是的，那是，那是几年前的事了，现在，现在我们在标准库中也有了 ranges，它，你知道的，我，我热爱 ranges，我热爱这种以集合为导向的东西，我，你知道的，就像你一样，它，我非常喜欢这种编程风格。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。